hello i'm greg sadler and i would love
to tell you about a great class coming
up that i'm very excited about hosted on
the light hall platform called aristotle
on the moral virtues and this is
something i'll tell you about in just a
minute i've been studying for decades
and applying in my own life and with
clients i think it's very
powerful and valuable
materials ideas practices distinctions
that you can apply and i do want to
address something right off the bat i've
had people already asking me questions
since i posted the class is this just
for people who already have a solid
background in philosophy or could
beginners benefit from this and the
answer is yes you can come into this
class as a completely raw beginner just
somebody who has an interest in the
notion of good moral character and how
to improve our lives so as to have that
and benefit ourselves and those around
us through that you'll be reading
aristotle i'm going to be leading you
through the text i'm providing you with
lots of resources just as i would for my
academic students in
colleges and universities where i've
been teaching this material for you know
over two decades at this point so you
could be a complete beginner so long as
you have some interest and you know a
desire to
read your way through aristotle with a
guide you'll benefit from it if you've
had some background you will get
something out of this as well even if
you've been studying aristotle for some
time
you're going to find in this class that
there's going to be some pointers some
practices some ideas that you might not
have
noticed up until this point so we're
looking at one of the most important
texts in ethics and particularly in
virtue ethics
really for several millennia one of the
big thinkers aristotle and what are we
going to do in the class so each class
session we're going to meet for 90
minutes students are going to have the
opportunity at the very beginning of the
class to raise a few questions address
some confusion some of it might be
terminological some of it might be
conceptual and then we'll jump right
into looking at the material for that
week and we're going to be going through
nick mccann ethics books
2
into book 6 over this 8 week period so a
good portion of the text itself so i'll
talk about what aristotle is saying and
then we'll you know have some discussion
and some q a and hopefully everybody
comes away from every session
with a solid understanding of not just
what aristotle is saying
but how you would apply it in your own
life to change the ways that you
approach situations how you think about
things the responses that you have both
action and volitional but also emotional
so a lot of stuff packed into every
single one of these sessions i do want
to lead you through the
we call it the itinerary right so in
session one which will be on tuesday
june 28th at noon central time
general features of virtues and vices
we're going to be doing some sort of an
overview this will be the introductory
lesson and we'll focus on nick mccann
ethics book 2 where aristotle tells us
quite a bit about this then from
session two
through session six we're going to be
looking at specific
virtues or clusters of virtues in
each of the
portions of the nickel mccain ethic so
session two virtues of courage and
temperance that's nick of mccain ethics
book three session three is going to be
devoted specifically to one virtue the
virtue of good temper or gentleness
something i do a lot of research on
having to do with anger we'll spend an
entire session on that
session four we're going to be looking
at wealth and other resources and how we
allocate them
you know who we devote them to so we're
looking at generosity and magnificence
also coming from nico mccann ethics book
four session five we're following that
up virtues of right ambition and
magnanimity or great soldness things
that have to do with honor and ambition
and social status
then session six we're going to be doing
a triple header looking at the so-called
social virtues the virtues of
friendliness good humor and truthfulness
in session seven we're going to be
looking at a more complicated virtue and
a set of issues namely those concerned
with
justice and that will be looking at nick
mccain ethics book
five and then we'll wrap up by looking
at some of the nico mccann ethics book
six discussions of prudence or practical
wisdom
how it figures into the moral virtues
and helps to guide them what its
connection is with other
you know what aristotle calls
intellectual virtues and why we in fact
need prudence and that will be our final
session for this this class so i'm
really excited about this as i think
many of you know from having seen my
videos or you know hearing me on
podcasts or reading blog entries or
other things that i've been in
one of the things that i do is take
complex philosophical topics texts
thinkers
and i help to make them understandable i
make them accessible for lifelong
learners working professionals students
even other professors who sometimes
struggle with the stuff so what you can
be guaranteed is if you take this class
with me you are going to come out with a
really solid both intellectual and
practical
understanding of how the aristotelian
virtues work what they include and
extend to and how to avoid the vices
opposed to them on both sides of
deficiency
and access so this is going to be a
great class i hope you can join me for
it and i look forward to interacting
with all of you learners in just a few
weeks
you